[Musique]
il t déjà arrivé un truc tellement
dingue que tu as pas réussi à y
croire nous avons mis au point une
neurotechnologie qui vous permettra de
devenir le meilleur de ce que vous êtes
vous restez vous-même mais dans votre
meilleure
version qui et
pourquoi c'est la bague
[Musique]
elle te ramène 57 secondes arrière c'est
hallucinant 7 le numéro de la
chance le
15 15 noir oui je vous
remercie tu as braqué une banque je suis
allé au casino j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance j'ai eu un petit
avantage Franklin qui est cette fille
c'est ma seœur jumelle Nathalie elle a
fait une overdose d'un antidouleur qu'on
lui a donné ce médicament a tué ma sœur
reç un désir de
justiceorenson a causé la mort de
milliers de personnes avec un médicament
dont il savait qu'il était hautement
addictif et mortel mais comment
m'assurer que ça n'arrive plus jamais
vous ne posez pas les bonnes questions
la véritable avancée c'est le voyage
dans le temp ignorez les rabois franlin
parce que je vous le dit l'argent fait
le
bonheur il ne s'agit plus de ta sœur ni
du monde tu ne penses plus qu'au
pouvoir ne laissez pas les craintes et
l'incertitude qui règne ici vous
empêcher de poursuivre ce qui brûle là
j'aurais aimé faire les choses
différemment C bague tu t'en es servi
pour
moi on peut pas sans cesse revenir en
arrière pour refaire les choses jusqu'à
ce qu'ell nous conviennent c'est à ça
que ressemble à meilleur avenir on n pas
assez de temps attachz V
[Musique]
ceintur